and every detail has been so
meticulously thought out let me see
those nails right
unbelievable i'm a designer get on over
here mister get on up here
thank you very much she is so inspiring
i love her i love her music i've always
loved it and also like you know when i
was asked her to come with me as a date
it was so inspiring just to say she was
just so full of it without hesitation
and also the fact that she did homework
and found out you know who i am i was
just like i was like you did that extra
work just for me like how do you not
know who you are
but like yeah she's been a dream to work
with i can't even tell her she was like
literally a cheerleader all right we're
going to do this and you'll see making
us laugh and really like it's amazing
you've got new music out are you going
to be performing up there tonight um i
am not but i am here they were like do
you want to do interviews i was like yes
i got an album out
emilia let's get that promo
and touring
yeah you know i would absolutely love to
tour this album i i love this album and
um so let's make it happen when is it
happening i don't know
i don't know but i want it to happen and
finally selfies are so famous here at
the mac gala we always see him the day
after
what is one attendee that you would love
to snag a selfie with here tonight in
that famed bathroom
i don't really i'm not i don't super
know who's coming but i just snagged a
selfie with strome
uh who i love so much so i was just like
i love them at gala it's already a win
[Music]